Given that humans have been using lead in
various product for over 8,000 years (with
the first known mining of it in Anatolia around
6500 BCE), you might be surprised to learn
that we have known that lead is dangerous
and shouldn’t be trifled with since at least
150 BC, when its effects on the human body
were noted by famed Greek physician Nicander
of Colophon.
Nicander even went so far as to describe the
metal as “deadly”, writing extensively
on the crippling effects it has on the human
body in his work, Alexipharmaca.
Further, Greek physician Pedanius Dioscorides
noted in the first century AD: “Lead makes
the mind give way”.
To quote the Occupation Safety and Health
Research Institute: “Lead poisoning is one
of the earliest identified and most known
occupational disease.
Its acute effects have been recognized from
antiquity.”
So what exactly does lead poisoning do to
the body?
Well, depending on how much of the substance
gets into your body (and it doesn’t take
much, particularly for children), it can cause
everything from constipation to permanent
reduction in your IQ and mental capacity.
It also can potentially fundamentally change
a given person’s personality, causing them
to be irritable and suffer from erratic mood-swings
and fatigue without warning; cause a reduction
in sperm count and infertility; stunted growth
(in children); miscarriages; and a whole slew
of other terrifying symptoms.
So that’s what it can do, but how?
Why is lead so dangerous to the human body
while we can safely ingest many other types
of metals, like iron, without worry (and,
in fact, need some of them to survive)?
While research is ongoing into the full effects
and mechanisms involved in lead poisoning,
what we do know is that a lot of the damage
is due to the fact that important things like
zinc, calcium, and iron in the body can ultimately
get replaced by lead in many key biochemical
reactions, if lead is present.
Unlike these other metals, though, while lead
is happy to bind and interact with various
critical enzymes, the result isn’t the normal
reaction you need.
For example, with calcium, as noted in this
paper on the Mechanisms of Lead Neurotoxicity,
lead has a nasty habit of being able to mimic,
or in some cases straight up inhibit the actions
of calcium in natural biological reactions
that take place within the human body, inhibiting
neurological function, among other things.
Lead also can damage DNA, as well as your
cell membranes, the latter of which, combined
with the fact that it also interferes with
heme synthesis, can result in anemia among
a host of other problems.
It can interfere with the ability for your
body to synthesize vitamin D, which comes
with yet another host of its own problems
if you don’t have enough.
It also causes a few different problems with
your immune system; interferes with metabolism
of bones and teeth; can cause abnormal calcium
build up within cells… the list goes on
and on and on.
If that wasn’t bad enough, lead can easily
find its way into almost any part of your
body once introduced, whether by breathing
it in, ingesting it, or (very rarely) via
skin absorption.
From this, you might find it completely unsurprising
that, unlike many other poisons, according
to the Centers for Disease Control and Prevention
lead is so toxic to humans that, “No safe
blood lead level has been identified.”
So, in short, lead is bad for you because,
though lead has no useful function in your
body, it’s happy to jump on in and give
it its best college try, interacting up a
storm with various enzymes, failing the whole
way at producing the reactions that are needed
for normal body function.
But what it lacks in end result, it makes
up for in staying power.
You see, the half-life of lead in the body
is quite long- weeks in your blood, months
in your soft tissues, and years in your bones;
and by years we mean up to two to three decades.
Who needs proper enzymatic function anyway?